the voice is revving up for season 19
after what was a chaotic crazy summer
big changes for all the coaches
especially kelly clarkson
she just revealed her divorce took her
totally by surprise
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
2020 has brought a lot of change to my
personal life
definitely didn't see anything coming
that came
hey my personal life is kind of like
what i'm dealing with is hard
because it involves a lot of little
hearts you know we have four kids and
divorce is never easy
everybody keeps asking are you okay are
you okay and i am the answer is yes
a source tells et the couple who married
seven years ago
had hoped quarantining in montana would
help them work things out
they were staying in this one-room cabin
there's where remy and river
sleep there's van buren asleep but
instead the change in environment
was actually detrimental
[Music]
[Applause]
our source says kelly's pouring
everything she has into her work to stay
busy
she just performed a medley of popular
tv theme songs on her show
[Music]
fellow coaches blake and gwen also made
a big change dropping more than 13
million
on their first house together this 13
000 square foot estate in la's encino
neighborhood
way more room than shelton's oklahoma
ranch where they spent quarantine
blake and i have been quarantining
together this entire time
i'm sorry gwen it's been pretty magical
for blake and i and the kids because we
don't ever have that much solid time
together
during quarantine i learned how to make
jam probably will never do that again
but now i know how to do it
as for john he and chrissy are expecting
their third child a boy
chrissy's on bed rest because she's
having a tough pregnancy
you know i didn't really get a chance to
come up with new hobbies
between trying to finish my album and
trying to promote it
and having two toddlers in the house hey
john same thing
two lives okay one second trying to hire
a homeschool teacher one second what can
we expect from the show
we're back in the studio we've already
done the blind auditions and we don't
have an audience
we're getting tested we're distancing
our chairs a little further apart
you